hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back with this installment
of our semi daily Q&A series today's
question is what are those sleep
requirements for a lifter for an athlete
is the typical recommendation of about
seven to eight hours per night enough
you know what are the drawbacks of
sleeping less than that and are there
benefits to sleeping more than that or
is that going to cause some drawbacks
that's an idea a lot of people have so
um first off just just to say this on
the outset this is mainly applicable
well this is primarily applicable to
people who have normal genetics for
sleep there are actually a few genes
that regulate how much you need to sleep
per night and the vast vast majority of
people have the typical allele for those
where a normal night of sleep is about
seven to eight and a half hours per
night there are some people a very small
minority of people like five percent of
the population or fewer that actually
have a gene that lets them for all
intents and purposes sleep faster so
they get as much out of a four to five
hour night of sleep as the typical
person would get out of an eight hour
night of sleep I'm very jealous of those
people and that very well may include
a lot of disproportionately successful
people who report sleeping hardly any at
all at night so those people are out
there but I'm assuming most of the
people I'm talking to you don't fall
into that category and you can't train
yourself to fall in that category
sleeping less and less you don't get
good at getting by on less sleep you
just feel really tired all the time
oh and one other thing to mention before
we get into this if you
are under sleeping you're probably not
the best judge of whether you're under
sleeping or not there was a study done
looking at mental performance with sleep
deprivation had people if I'm
remembering correctly sleeping six hours
per night and then while one group
sleeping six hours per night one group
sleeping I think eight and a half hours
per night and then one group was playing
consecutive all-nighters and the six
hour group they when basically they ran
them through mental tasks and look to
see what their performance actually was
and then ask them how much do you think
your performance has declined and they
they said correctly that they felt their
performance had declined after 24 hours
then by 48 hours if I'm remembering
correctly they said yeah I think I I'm
doing just as well as I did yesterday
you know haven't gotten any worse but
not as good as a full night of sleep and
then same thing after three days of poor
sleep they thought that their
performance was below baseline but
hadn't really declined any more win in
reality their performance had just
declined linearly all three days so they
didn't realize how sleep-deprived they
were they felt that they a kind of
plateaued after one night of bad sleep
when actually after three days of
sleeping six hours per night their
mental performance was about the same as
it would have been if they pulled an
all-nighter so whoo yeah that's that's
just a random aside before we actually
get into the video
okay so first core the the main question
you know are there benefits to sleeping
more and what are the drawbacks to
sleeping less I'll address this the
second part of that question first
because that's what most of the research
thus far is kind of looking at so
there's a lot of research comparing
sleeping a normal amount seven eight and
a half hours or so to sleep being
substantially less than that so they
typically use five and a half to six
hours in those studies as the short
sleeping group and I'll just sum all of
that up very quickly a bunch of bad [ __ ]
happens and no good [ __ ] happens
physical performance goes down mental
performance goes down just become
crankier that's that's not a good thing
if you're a fast sleeper and you can get
by on that that's great for most of us
sleeping at least seven and a half eight
eight and a half hours per night is
going to be dramatically better than
sleeping less than that both in terms of
just how you feel
and then also probably how you'll
respond to training and diet as well
there haven't been that many long-term
studies looking at this partially
because it's not incredibly ethical to
make people sleep less for prolonged
periods of time I am hard to run RCTs on
that because like ethic sports know that
that's a very unhealthy thing and so
it's hard to actually perform research
on that but some things we do know is
there have been relatively short-term
studies but long enough to get a good
idea of what's going on looking at
short-sleeved versus normal amounts of
sleep on body composition in a calorie
deficit and they find that when you're
sleeping less you lose the same amount
of actual weight as when you're sleeping
more when diet is controlled but more of
that weight lost is lean mass and less
of it is fat mass so that's no good
and then in terms of population wide
studies people who sleep less tend to
have more body fat higher BMIs
whereas health outcomes so that would
probably primarily apply to a calorie
surplus or at maintenance so yeah short
answer there if you're sleeping less
than at least seven and a half hours per
night you're probably going to benefit a
lot like a very meaningful amount by you
know trying to get you know trying to
get a bed at least eight hours per night
or so the more interesting question is
are there additional benefits on top of
that to sleeping more than eight hours
per night and this it doesn't have quite
as much research to this point and for a
long time people recommend it against
this even for healthy athletes because
there is some population at the
epidemiological research showing that
people who sleep longer than about eight
eight and a half hours per night tend to
have worse health outcomes than people
who do sleep kind of a more normal
amount but that very well could be and
probably is a case of mistaken causality
so it's not necessarily that sleeping
more is bad for you
what's probably going on there is people
who are already unhealthy are fatigued
and need to sleep more or don't have
jobs and are less busy and can sleep
more and that's also associated
generally with Werth's life outcomes in
general so that's that's a concern a lot
of people have I think that that is
probably just a case of mistaken
causality they're just assuming
correlation is causation when it's
actually not now in terms of actual
controlled research done on sleep
extension there's not too much at this
point most of it is coming out of Sherry
Maas lab at Stanford University and I
will just admit on the front end it's
they haven't looked at anything having
to do with strength hypertrophy power
lifting bodybuilding anything like that
to this point it's been looking
primarily at you know other athletes of
you know the types of sports that more
people in the world care about just
being Frank about it
so they've looked at tennis swimming
basketball and I think football but I
know tennis swimming and basketball and
so they've looked at some stuff that
would primarily be associated more focus
and mental performance so you know
free-throw shooting accuracy three-point
shooting accuracy
serve accuracy and return accuracy in
tennis but they have also looked at just
more pure performance based things so
for the basketball players sprint times
for the swimmers
sprint times over fairly short distances
and they found man I wish I would have
got the exact numbers but pretty
dramatic improvements so we're talking I
like 5 to 8% decreases in sprint times
on average which if you've ever looked
if you've ever worked with athletes
where sprint times are important that's
a huge drop like that's the type of drop
that you'd be looking at for maybe like
a six month to a year long training
cycle and we're talking those are the
benefits associated with about two weeks
of sleep extension so having them go
from sleeping about eight hours per
night to nine to ten hours per night so
like you can't draw a straight line
between sprint times and your lifts in
the gym or hypertrophy I'm not claiming
that for a moment but I am saying that
you know sprint times that's primarily
power output that is closely associated
with force output you're just generally
less mentally fatigued so you will
probably be able to train harder recover
faster
so in general I definitely think to this
point the research is leaning towards if
you can sleep 9 to 10 hours per night if
you have time for that in your schedule
you will probably get additional maybe
substantial benefits from sleeping an
extra hour to per night even if you're
already sleeping a normal amount seven
and a half eight hours per night
typically so that is the video if you're
sleeping five six hours per night now
and you feel like garbage you're
probably not one of those lucky fastest
Leber's definitely sleep more if you can
make time in your schedule get in bed an
extra hour to pronate that is going to
pay big dividends for you if you're
already sleeping seven and a half eight
hours per night and you're training hard
you will probably also get some benefits
from sleeping an extra hour so if you
can fit that into your schedule but it's
probably not going to be a night and day
difference so you know don't freak
yourself out if if that's just not
possible for you but if it is it is
definitely worth a shot over two or
three weeks just see if it makes a
difference for you
just for myself it's something that I I
believe strongly in
from my experiences with it I do
typically sleep about seven to eight
hours per night but the two best
training blocks I've had since just my
initial noob gains in a decade ago when
I started training or whatever since
that point the two best training cycles
I've had once I've already been in a
well trained state were two periods of
my life when I did have just fewer
responsibilities and I could get in bed
an average of about eight and a half to
ten hours per night depending on on the
night of the week and that that did make
at least for me anecdotally a big
difference in terms of my results how
quickly I gained strength and how well I
recovered from training so if that's
something that you do have room in your
schedule to to give a try I think it's I
think it's definitely worth a crack if
you can this was a little bit more of a
family video than normal sleep is
something that I tend to get pretty
passionate about one of the few topics
that I do get really preachy about
because I do think it is very very
important and a lot of times its
importance is understated and it's not
talked about as much because you know
sleeps not as sexy is something like a
cool training program new diet ideas
supplement whatever so I feel like it
doesn't get as much love as it should
but it is a very very important topic
and you know you should try to sleep
probably about as much as you can as
much as your schedule allows so that is
the video if you liked it too please
like and subscribe and if you have a
question you want answered ask it in the
comments below and if it is my favorite
I will pick it and answer it in that
next video alright guys thanks for
watching and until next time hope your
training is great hope you have a great
weekend and I will see you in that next
video